He is risen.
Risen. Okay, good. I love that.
Some of you're clapping and some of you said what, right?
So, uh, he is risen. He is risen. There you go.
I, I'm happy with either one of those, right? Yeah.
Um, what a great problem to have.
We've got people sitting in the hallway over here.
We got people sitting along the wall, like,
praise God for that, right?
Like just, uh, thank you for being flexible.
I know this is chaos. It's beautiful chaos,
but it is so, uh, just, we can make it right.
We'll do this, okay? Uh, if you're new
to our church, my name is John.
I'm one of the pastors here.
We're grateful you choose to be here.
Uh, please let us know if you are new and,
and kind of looking to, uh,
take a step forward with the church.
We've got people at the front right of here afterwards,
but specifically the new here area out there would be your
best bet to go introduce yourself, get to know us, and,
and we would get to know you a little bit.
Please let us do that. We'd love to.
Uh, but we are here on the highest peak of all the mountains
of our faith called Resurrection Day.
And so it is a, a gathering that we
don't do anything different than we do every
other Sunday of the year.
But it just seems like it matters a little bit more,
even though it's not.
But, but really what I'm gonna talk about today is
what Tim call Tim Keller called the hinge upon which the
story of the world pivots.
That's how critical this really is. How important this is.
It's the resurrection of Christ, that he was dead
for three days and now he's alive.
Like that's the simple base level message of it.
Which if that is true, that changes everything.
It makes unbelief implausible.
But if that is false, if it's untrue,
if he didn't really come back from the grave,
that changes everything as well, doesn't it?
It makes belief implausible.
That's how critical Easter really is.
Everything rises or falls on whether he stayed dead
or whether he came outta that grave alive.
Now, many people don't believe
that he did come back to life.
Some would say that it's scientifically impossible
for someone to die three days later to come back to life.
It just can't happen. Some of you might be in that frame
of mind right now, and you just got
drug here 'cause your family came.
That's it's real happens.
But there are some of us who, who would believe that?
Who would say, yeah, of course Jesus resurrected, we believe
that, but, but you don't really understand the meaning
of why it matters
or how it affects our lives to
and forever hope to clear up some of those things today
as we go into God's word,
which is one Corinthians 15 for us today.
So take your copy, God's word, turn there with me,
one Corinthians 15.
It's in the New Testament. Later in the Bible you'll find a,
a longer book, one Corinthians.
If you don't have a Bible, uh, you can find one
underneath the seat around you or in front of you.
Uh, if you don't own a Bible at all,
please take that home as our gift to you.
We'd love to let you take that
and read who God is through that.
We're gonna begin a new series next week, by the way,
in First Corinthians, so just kind of continuing on
a little bit in that book,
but just as a bit of background as we go into this today,
the, the apostle Paul was writing this letter to
the church in Corinth
and they'd asked him a series of questions.
They were looking for answers from a leader in the church.
And so they were saying, Hey, what, what do we do with this?
How do we handle this? How do we respond here?
And part of those questions dealt with resurrection.
And so Paul here in one Corinthians 15,
he spent 11 verses explaining the basic gospel message,
the good news that Jesus died.
He was buried. And he raised again, like that's the essence,
the core, the basic.
But he also said to them
that this was not just a made up story, like a group
of 12 guys got together
and came up with this awesome way
to change the world or change their lives.
And so it wasn't just a made up story
because actually about 500 people saw Jesus alive
after he was obviously dead and buried.
So he is saying, you guys can believe this,
this is the gospel, the good news.
But there were some people in Corinth who denied
that resurrection is even possible.
There's no way that just does not happen.
Or, or maybe they might have believed that the soul
lasts forever, but the body just kind of fades away.
It's not important. And so
that's why Paul then goes into this to explain
to them the consequences of denying resurrection.
Okay guys, so you believe resurrection's impossible.
So, so let me explain to you the implications of that.
Let me argue why you shouldn't,
but also tell me,
tell you why it gets down the road as it does.
And so we're gonna see it here, the consequences
of denying resurrection just in general at all.
And we'll see it here. First Corinthians chapter
15, starting in verse 12.
I'll read a few verses then we'll
talk about it a little bit.
Now, if Christ is proclaimed as raised from the dead,
how can some of you say that there is no resurrection
of the dead, but if there is no resurrection of the dead,
then not even Christ has been raised.
And if Christ has not been raised,
then our preaching is in vain and your faith is in vain.
We are even found to be misrepresenting God
because we testified about God
that he raised Christ whom he did not raise.
If it's true that the dead are not raised for,
if the dead are not raised, not even Christ has been raised,
and if Christ has not been raised, your faith is futile
and you are still in your sins,
then those also who've fallen asleep
or died in Christ have perished.
If in Christ we have hope in this life only we are
of all people most to be pitied.
So notice how Paul went about this.
He gets the question about resurrection and,
and he goes about it in a really logical,
reasoned kind of way.
So you, you see if then statements,
you see him repeat himself, you see him follow logic to say,
well, if you believe this, here's next.
You believe that? Well here's next.
Here's the logical implications of denying
that resurrection's even possible.
And notice what he says first he says
that if someone believes that, then what you're saying is
that our testimony is a lie, right?
So he's an apostle, he's proclaiming the gospel
to the world, he's taking it out to the nations.
And he says, if you're saying denying resurrection is
where you believe, then,
then you're telling us that we're lying.
'cause remember, he's talking to people
who he assumed were believers, they're in the church.
And so he's saying, you, you,
you guys believe this stuff, right?
But if Christ is proclaimed as raised from the dead,
a basic tenet of our faith, how can you even say
that there's no resurrection at all?
That's the foundational part of our beliefs.
It doesn't make any sense for you to deny, resurrection
and still be a Christian.
Plus it again, accuses the apostles of lying.
That's what verse 15 says.
They'd be found to be misrepresenting God.
They said he did, but he didn't.
If they believe that, okay, so how does that apply?
Well, what's the logic for us then?
Well, if we deny that resurrection can happen at all,
then, then that's to turn around
and also say that anyone who preaches
that message is a liar.
By the way, it's also to say
that the New Testament is lying to us.
And it's also to say that Jesus himself was a liar
because he said, I'm coming back after the third day
because if resurrection is
impossible, then our message
that Christ has been raised is actually untrue.
We've made up a story.
We're lying to get people on our side even though it's a
foundational element of our faith as Christians.
It's not true if we deny resurrection.
But, but here's, here's maybe the, the worst part of this
that would also mean then that Christ is still dead.
Like if we deny resurrection,
that means Christ is still dead.
That's what you see in verses 13 and 16.
He repeats himself almost exactly.
He says, if the dead are not raised,
then not even Christ has been raised.
And that's a massive problem, right?
See, if Jesus had died never to be raised again,
then what that means is that it proves
that death could take the loveliest and best life ever
and finally break it.
Death would win.
That there's, there's something that, that,
that means there's no hope because there's something
stronger than God.
That means the tomb is still sealed
and Christ is still dead.
That's still back there.
He, his bones are still in that tomb.
It also means then though along with that,
if you deny resurrection verses 14, 17,
and 18, say then that our faith is futile.
If you deny resurrection our faith, if Christ is still dead,
our faith is useless,
our preaching is empty, our belief is in vain.
And and he says it here, you are still in your sins.
Now, how does that work? Well follow this one.
Peter two says
that Christ bore our sins in his body on the
tree, on the cross.
So there, there is a measure
of when he was dying on the cross
in shedding his atoning blood.
It pays for covers our sin,
but the victory over those
sins actually occurs when he walked out
of the grave alive, right?
So, so you see there's parts here.
He, he did part of it here, part of it here.
And all of that matters together.
But, but, so lemme try to illustrate this
for you a little bit.
It's not perfect, but it's at least something we can
kind of grasp here.
Imagine you and I are wrapped up in our sins.
We're we are enslaved by our sin.
Where, where we can't get out, there's nothing we can do
to get out of those sins.
But when Christ died,
when I put my faith in his work in my place,
then the scripture says I effectively died with him.
And what that means is
because of his blood, it means that those chains are broken.
That I have been set free from sin.
Now those chains have been broken,
their power has been cut off.
But those chains can still be heavy, can't they?
So again, just imagine you're wrapped up with chains and,
and, and you're sitting there before and you can't get out.
There's no way out. But when Christ died, it broke the power
of those chains.
It broke them open.
So you're released now, but,
but we can still sit there wrapped up, can't we?
We can still stay kept down.
We could remain in that place where the power's been broken,
but we stay in that stage.
But since they've been broken, remember if they're not
powerful anymore, you can literally walk right out of them.
Now that's, if, that's exactly what Romans six says.
It says, just as Christ was raised from the dead
by the glory of the Father, we too might walk in newness
of life that the chains have been broken
and we have the power in Christ new to walk out of him.
That's the idea of the resurrection, illustrating
that not only are the power of the chains
and sin broken, you now have the ability
to walk in a new life, out of the tomb, out of the chains
that you couldn't before.
Were set free from sin by his death,
but were given new life.
By his resurrection, he defeated death.
So we don't have to lay in it anymore.
That's why without resurrection, our faith is fruitless.
Death still wins in the end.
We don't have hope of eternal life.
We are still in our sins.
We don't have the ability to walk towards life eternal
'cause we're still there.
And and listen, he, he was writing to people
who were worried about this.
If you die, so imagine Christ hasn't been resurrected.
If you die, he says you perish eternal.
That perish word is a, an eternal judgment kind of word.
You're still in your sins and you perish.
And so you, you're thinking about that person.
These people are thinking about the brothers
and sisters that died in Christ.
They were believers. What happens to them?
It says, if Christ
hasn't been raised, they're, they're done.
You perish. Same for us.
That's why the fourth consequence
of denying resurrection is
that our life is pitiable as a result.
Like if we stand here
and deny resurrection,
If we're basing our eternal hope on a lie,
then we deserve pity.
All this that we're doing here today is a massive waste
of time right there.
There are a whole lot of other things we could be doing
that would be more fun than sitting here listening
to a guy talk for 30 minutes in.
In fact, not only are we wasting our time, but
but just think about how we, we choose to do things
and not do things because we're Christians,
because we talk about this, we believe the Bible,
we're doing these things and we're saying
where I'm not gonna do this.
I'm gonna do this and, and we make our lives harder.
If Christ has not been raised,
we're doing all that for no reason.
We're making our lives harder for no reason.
We might as well just go live it up.
We might as well just go have a good time
because in the end there's no consequence.
We might as well just go use everyone
and use everything
to give ourselves the highest pleasure we can find in this
moment right here and now there's no consequence,
there's nothing after this anyway.
So we might as well just go enjoy ourselves.
Isn't that the prevailing thought of our culture though?
Isn't that the way that almost animal-like in our instincts
that we just say right here
and now, this is all that matters.
I'm gonna get the highest level
of pleasure I can out of this.
But when you think about it, if there is no resurrection,
that makes total sense, doesn't it?
This is all there is here
and now I might as well get as most out of it as I can.
But what do you get in the end?
You don't get endless hope. What you get is a hopeless end.
That's why we kind of spend our lives trying to avoid death,
trying to not talk about it, trying to push it off as far
as, because this, this is all there is.
Gotta make the most of it. Gotta live it out.
Well, thankfully, on this resurrection day,
that's not the end of the passage, right?
That's pretty hopeless, pretty miserable at this point.
We're just here trusting in a delusion.
Verse 20 of one Corinthians 15, verse 20 corrects us.
But look for those words throughout scripture.
Those are key words. They're transitions.
They say, Hey, on the contrary,
but in fact,
Christ has been raised from the dead, right?
So, so he's saying over
and over again, he's saying, here's what happens.
If you don't believe this, if you don't believe it all,
if you don't believe
resurrection's possible, here's what you get.
But in fact, Christ has been raised from the dead
'cause remember, the foundation
and fabric of our faith falls apart.
If he hasn't been raised.
There's no reason for us to be here.
There's absolutely no reason for us to do what we are doing.
But praise God that he has,
and the word that he has been raised, it's a continual word.
It's a word that means he didn't just raise one time
and then probably died later.
He raised continually staying as the risen Lord permanently.
That's this idea of he has raised, that's
what I wanna shift now to.
We talked about the consequences of denying resurrection.
What about the consequences of Christ's resurrection?
What are the implications of that?
We know what happens when we deny it.
What happens now because of it?
Look at verses 20 through 26,
by the way, again, he says, fallen asleep, that means died.
It's a great illustration of
what we're gonna talk about here in a second.
Just keep that in mind.
But in fact, Christ has been raised from the dead.
The first fruits of those who have fallen asleep for as
by a man came death by a man has come also the resurrection
of the dead for as in Adam all die.
So also in Christ shall all be made alive.
But each in his own order, Christ the first fruits,
then at his coming, those who belong to Christ
then comes the end.
When he delivers the kingdom to God, the Father,
after destroying every rule and every authority
and every power for he must reign
until he's put all his enemies under his feet,
the last enemy to be destroyed is death.
So what happens? Because Christ arose?
Well, first what we learn is that that means
resurrection's coming for believers too, right?
What are the implications of Christ's resurrection?
Believers get resurrection as well.
This is all the first fruit stuff
that Paul wrote about here.
You might not understand that. That's fine.
It's, it's explained here in a little bit when
you think about it.
Paul was probably picturing the Passover feast.
You might remember that from the Old Testament
history of the Exodus.
When God's people get released from slavery out of Egypt,
it began the Passover festival.
And so they would celebrate that,
but at the same time, it was also a great harvest festival.
It was at the same kind of time
of year when those things would coincide.
And so when you go back to the Old Testament, Leviticus 23,
where I know you stopped in your reading plan this year,
you gave it up at that point.
But Leviticus 23 is where
God commands his people to bring the first fruits,
the the first best batch of the harvest to the tabernacle
to say offer it to God.
And that was an illustration then of
what they would then go back
and receive the rest of the harvest.
They couldn't touch it, they couldn't use it,
they couldn't sell it.
They couldn't do any of that with the rest of it
until they offered the first fruits.
But, but in a sense, this first fruit offering was a sign
of the harvest to come.
Is that not what we see here with the resurrection of Jesus?
It was a sign of the resurrection
of believers that's coming later.
The first fruits for those
who belong to Christ.
Notice it says this is the first fruits,
this is the first example of what's going to happen later.
He's first then his people.
I wanna clarify something about this resurrection.
See, what we talk about and think about often is, is that
whenever we're resurrected, there's gonna be some kind
of like we're we're floating around on clouds with harps
and somehow we're gonna be this disembodied.
Somehow we get wings outta this thing.
I'm not sure how that works, but we're, we're floating
through and, and it's just this weird eternal sort of moment
or that we're gonna be reincarnated into something based on
our works here and it's based on levels then
that's not at all what this is.
When we talk about the resurrection that you
as a believer will receive.
It is actually you resurrected
where you get a new fully human body
just like Jesus's was.
Because remember when he was resurrected,
you see people coming up to him
and they're like, are you real?
Like they think he's a ghost in some ways.
And, and what they could do is they could put their
fingers in the wounds.
They could in his side, they could touch
him, they could hug him.
He was eating food. He was a figure, a human body,
you know, it was very different,
but it was still a human body that was remade.
It's what you and I believers will receive as well.
Not only will receive a new body will also be brought into
a world that is incomparably more
desirable than this one is.
Like, man, we try to make this as great as we can.
We try to look for everything we can.
This is nice and it's great to get in creation
and worship God, but we can't even see a glimmer in this
of what it's gonna be someday.
That's the resurrection that Christ was the first fruits of
that we as believers will receive as well.
But I, but I know like how, how's it even possible?
How's that possible for us to receive that blessed benefit?
I mean, Christ did it. Okay, I get it. He's God.
But how do we get that?
It's through what Paul wrote here about Adam
and our connection to Adam.
Now this is Adam from the Adam and Eve.
Genesis 1, 2, 3 story, right?
First human in a way,
our representative head you might say,
because at the time the Jews believed that when Adam sinned,
all of us, the whole human race effectively sinned with him
since we were from him.
And so we're all then guilty.
That's how sin and death entered our
lives, entered the world.
It's through Adam and we are all caught up in it.
And some people think, well, that's not fair.
Okay, well you sin too, don't you?
I sin like I'm just as guilty.
We're all stuck in this
and we're all then as sinners deserving of death.
But with the coming of Christ, that cycle was broken.
'cause remember, he was not of the seed of Adam.
The cycle was broken.
And so Jesus sinless and he conquered death.
What that means is that when we, we connect, unify with him,
the the, the ability we have to receive
what he offers is now a new power that overcomes
what we once were connected to.
We're still connected, Adam, we're still physically dying.
Yes, but the new power in Christ, this
sinless Christ breaks the power so that we're not tied
to the death of Adam anymore.
The spiritual death of Adam.
We have a new hope, a new power in Christ.
In fact, that's the illustration he gives here in verse 23.
He uses the word order.
You see that, but each in his own order,
that order word is a military term
that in a sense, there, there's like two waves.
Uh, you think of a military, especially the old times
of military where they'd go in waves of troops battle line
and they'd just go in waves, right?
In a sense, there's two waves in this battle.
First captain Jesus, he's leading the charge
and he's going out on his own.
And we are, he's, we're following him as his troops.
The believers are right behind him.
He's charged ahead
and we're following along in the same direction right
behind him as he goes into this battle.
You think about it like the pictures you get
and the images you get of those battles, how fearful
that would be where you're walk, walking in line,
marching towards the battle line
and you're about to meet how fearful you would be.
Are we gonna overcome this? Are we gonna win?
Well, this battle is different.
We can run behind our captain
victoriously knowing that we are going to be
and confident we're going to be victorious
because just ahead of us, what we've watched is our victor.
He's already pierced
through the battle line on the other side,
and we're coming right behind him
and we don't have to worry
about whether we're gonna win or not.
We've already seen, he's won the battle for us
and we walk right behind him, that enemy line of death
and sin has been broken in him.
We receive the benefit.
And that's good news on its own, right?
But that's not even it. There's more here.
But because then he says in verse 24, then comes the end.
So we've watched him pierce through the enemy line already,
but then comes the end where at some future climax,
Christ will fully destroy even death.
He's already defeated it, but some days come
and he's gonna fully destroy it and put it away.
How great is that? And listen, I know how good news
that is because I know what it feels like
to lose a hero, grandpa.
And I know what it feels like to, to wrestle
with an uncertain medical diagnosis.
And you, you don't, you don't know what the next days hold
and, and you don't know when you're struggling
day by day through this emotional concern
or this family struggle
and you're just thinking there is no end to this ever.
This is good news
because what it means is that life is certain in Christ.
Yes, life eternal, the resurrection.
We're gonna live forever. But I'm talking about something
more than just that physical life forever.
I'm talking about true new life.
That's what this is referring to,
that life is certain in Christ.
And what that means is that there's coming a day
when this resurrected Christ will destroy every power
that has come against him, where he will,
he will crush the enemy under his feet.
Right now, he's already got
that like the old WWF stuff, right?
They're hanging on the rope. He's got his enemy under his
foot, on his neck, right?
Just yanking on. He's already got that.
He's already in authority over the enemy.
But there's a day coming, they'll be completely gone.
Even death that
that's the enemy you and I can do nothing about, right?
Every other enemy in our lives,
we can do something about it.
We can get bigger guns, bigger bombs.
We, we can, we can go through the better defense systems
around our house or around our social structure
or we, we can attack medically
or systematically or scientifically.
We can do all kinds of stuff against the enemies we face
here and now.
But there is no pill. There's no cream.
There's no thing that can keep death at bay.
It's coming for us. Every one of us.
We cannot keep it away.
And listen, there's even a time 2000 years ago when God,
the son took on a human nature
and he was on that cross, that old rugged cross.
There was a moment in history where
death thought it had won.
But three days later,
but three days later, death
was swallowed up in victory, right?
Because death is a strong enemy. Absolutely.
But believers do not have to fear death
because resurrection wins.
We don't have to look death in the face,
whether it's our own death
and we're just like, no, no, no, I don't want to stay away
or, or it's the death of a loved one
or it's sickness or trials.
We don't have to look at that with fear
because we know God wins and he will reign fully
and finally forever.
And so for the believer, there's no fear in death anymore
because two Timothy one 10 says, Christ has destroyed death
and has brought life
and immortality to light through the gospel.
So friends, this is the meaning of Easter.
The Son of God came on a mission to defeat sin,
to vanquish death and to liberate mankind.
Do you believe this?
Jesus says in John 11,
I am the resurrection and the life.
Whoever believes in me, though he die yet shall he live.
And everyone who lives and believes in me shall never
die. Do you believe
This?
So maybe you think that resurrection's impossible,
or maybe you think that resurrection is only
for those people who aren't as bad as you are.
Or maybe you're just not even sure how the benefits Christ
purchased apply to you.
How about we instead reorient our beliefs around
what God's word has said, which leads us,
and I hope you've seen this today, it leads us to the hope
of Christ's resurrection for us.
Something That gives us not just hope forever and ever
and like, well, yeah, we'll get that someday,
but a living hope
today that changes everything.
Do you believe this.